moves let me get out of this uh hot
water and uh
let's start again i think magnus will be
kicking himself if this is a draw though
because he will have known earlier that
he was doing very well jordan's pawns
were so ugly uh okay moment of truth is
magnus gonna go towards the night if he
brings his king down the board just like
he did earlier we will see a draw most
likely so if magnus goes back to the top
of the board he's playing for the win
moment of truth i think he's going to
play for the draw i think he'll play for
the win i mean uh i don't see anything
wrong with king g8 so why not player
there's nothing immediately wrong
okay
oh i'm changing my mind quickly there
bit late there
bit later i won the bet there yeah you
certainly won that bet and it's going to
have a draw you guys in game one with
jordan and
magnus some uh impressive play by jordan
there's some amazing compliments by
magnus to some by david sorry to some of
his moves players are leaving the oslo a